welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and spiderman far from home swung
the mcu to a bright future
where no one can believe anything ever
with this being the final film of our
infinity saga rewatch series
let us break down all the subtle visual
details and easter eggs we
missed in past reviews to explore the
endless lengths mysterio and this film
as a whole
so effectively messed with our heads the
opening scene immediately hits us with a
ton of lies
the monster that destroyed this mexican
town isn't a sand man as you might
deduce from that few
easter egg on the license plate 463 for
spider-man 4
released in 1963 the debut of sandman
flint marco because director john watts
knew that we would look at the license
plates after homecoming so now
463 is just a misdirect that he
deliberately included in trailer footage
even even nick fury and maria hill are
lies
they're actually the skrulls talos and
soren hinted at by
hill's line here nick this was a tragedy
but it's not why we're here
in captain marvel fury clarified that no
one calls him nick
everybody calls me fury not nicholas not
joseph not
nick just fury and that is how he first
spotted taylors
excellent work nicholas
later in this movie hill calls fury nick
again secret information nick
satellites are picking up an em pulse
now sure people have called fury nick
plenty of other times in the mcu and
maybe hill is just more familiar
with him but these are the first
prominent violations of the rule
after it was established in captain
marvel like we can't fault past movies
for not knowing captain marvel would set
that rule in the future but
far from home is going out of its way to
violate it now
and quintin beck arrives you don't want
any part of this
he always tells them to stay back and
let him be the hero
you should get some more safe fury i
don't see this ending well
i appreciate your concern but i never
leave my men behind
because fury and telos know that
strength comes from cooperation
teamwork not one man alone trying to fix
things
the midtown morning news blip recap
shows the moment the marching band
undusted and i love how the basketball
gets passed directly into the tuba and
skews its note
in the news there's a boom in the shot
and we get betty's eye line fail
as we draw this year to a close it's
time to move
on to a new phase of our lives
one of the few nods to marvel moving on
to phase four
some people move on but not youtube
channels trying to make content despite
marvel production delays peter and ed's
classroom is filled with iron man
tribute art like the murals that keep
reappearing throughout this movie
constantly reminding peter that this is
all a feud over stark's legacy
does stark's tech go to the beneficiary
he chose despite him being kind of a
dope or
should it go to smarter adults who
worked their asses off for it
but you know are kind of evil happy's
big check is from stark industries
signed by pepper potts
suggesting the company is still active
but also visible here is an old
wrestling poster
listing crusher hogan the wrestler peter
tested his powers against in the comics
but also bone
saw mcgraw the rainy movie version of
that character played by matchman randy
savage
i got you for three minutes three
minutes of plea
time oh yeah one of a few very
interesting tie-ins between the mcu
and the rainy verse that i pray gets
whipped together in a spider-verse one
of spider-man's fans holds up the photo
of peter coming out of the porta-potty
the same one that the news used as a
stock photo of him in homecoming
peter's phone screen is cracked again
not as spider-webby as the end of
homecoming but he's still got some of
that wed slinging in him and his
suitcase is labeled bfp
belonging to his uncle ben parker may
hits him with a banana
hungry
so sorry i thought that you could sense
that with your
peter tingle peter's spidey sense is
still recovering from the trauma of him
sensing his dusty and infinity war
does it start i don't feel so good
peter is flying blind in this movie
especially vulnerable to the deeper
theme of far from home
the danger of misperception it may
haunts him with this
shame forcing peter to carry it with him
to europe also notice how peter taped
over his light switch he's forcing it to
stay on
always because it's connected to the
outlet below notice how he runs
all of his stuff through that power
strip and the light switch has to stay
on
to keep his iron spider charger running
that energy bill must be
rough peter's in-flight movie selections
include the snap directed by paul
greengrass
suggesting a captain phillips or united
93 style take on the events of infinity
war finding wakanda
hunt and hydra and nova directed by
thor's favorite astrophysicist and band
from stonehenge dr eric selvig there's
also a title called heart of iron the
tony stark story
which i have wondered could be a nod to
iron hearts riri williams
mit student and stark follower who might
have been in the crowd for that barf
presentation
when ned plays b slayers his avatar
looks like him and he wins by using the
halberd weapon
later in the tower of london he corrects
happy regarding the same kind of weapon
give me the spear that's a helper
in venice the kids take a selfie
a pizza time now to peter parker as the
delivery guy and rainey's spider-man 2
pizza time mr harrington drops his phone
actually the end credits
show the last photo taken as he dropped
it which might have been automatic
because you know he wasn't holding it or
maybe a drone took the photo
and again mysterio's deception is
everywhere i pointed out last year how
quentin beck hides in plain sight
as a tourist behind peter and later
creeping behind peter and mj
is gutermin to mysterious screenwriter
gootz
mysterio's water monster rises from
drones in the canals but mysterio
himself first appears
literally out of thin air since you know
he's just a projection when peter holds
the bell tower from falling he's keeping
it from crushing an
orphanage oh not the orphans especially
since you know
peter is one flash says buzzfeed says
there's a sailor named morris bench who
was exposed to an experimental
underwater generator and got hydro
powers ah maury bench is the classic
comics origin of spidey villain hydra
man but mj is right to tell him not to
believe everything he reads on the
internet
a movie about misperception but mj's
just as prone to conspiracy theories
because she says this about eiffel tower
i read it was secretly built as a mind
control antenna to create an army of the
insane
a bit of foreshadowing setting up how
mysterio will use eiffel tower to try to
control peter's mind and drive him
insane
taylor slash fury drops another clue
about his off-world origin
uh mr bett is from earth
just not yours the line that was changed
from
hours in promotional footage back is
from earth just not ours
and then beck explains this is earth
dimension 616. i'm from earth 833
earth 616 is the main marvel comics
universe the marvel cinematic universe
is technically earth19999
earth 833 is the comics universe home to
spider uk
maybe a nod to peter's battles in london
in the final act of this movie the
hollow projection forms this halo around
beck's head
making the shape of his fishbowl style
helmet they also show mythological
figures from real human history that
beck says the elementals were based on
the way thor was rooted in human norse
mythology
of course beck's story is [ __ ] but
just like the multiverse is still a real
thing in the marvel world these
actual mythological figures could be
linked with the upcoming
eternals the venice street names are all
nods to spiderman comics writers and
artists project d
g is for jerry conway who gave us the
death of gwen stacey
bienvendisto is for brian michael bendis
miles morales co-creator long time
comics writer d
michellenio is for david michelini
venom creator campo de r sterno is for
roger stern creator of hobgoblin
and caille desloto is for spider-man
writer dan slott
peter puts on tony's glasses similar to
frames tony war infinity war and links
with edith and this key prop of the
movie is another example of the
misperception motif peter flying blind
wants the insight tony stark had but he
has not yet proven himself
worthy to inherit that vision edith
shows everyone's screens
mr dell is looking up witchcraft after
suspecting mysterio to be witch-related
mr harrington is texting someone finally
some good luck a poor guy
another student texas mom for more money
dimitri's is encrypted
brad is searching for romantic spots in
prague
just like peter was doing moments
earlier and flash texts that he hasn't
heard from his parents and at the end of
the movie they don't pick him up from
the airport we've made a couple theories
about that but really i just think he
could just be
rich and his parents don't care about
him peter gets a new stealth suit which
he later describes as
he's a little tight around the old web
shooter parker well since this suit came
from fury slash talos and since that
unit was infiltrated by team mysterio
it is possible that mysterio could have
corrupted the suit to make peter easier
to manipulate
if we think about it it is a stealth
suit certainly sets a mysterio to be the
flashier hero
have all the cameras point to him and
also worth noting that peter has to lose
this suit
and make his own new suit in order to
defeat mysterio in the end of the movie
when peter distracts everyone on the bus
away from him jumping up to take out the
drone
mj has not leaned over to look out the
window so peter would be in her eye line
and notice how her suspicious eye is
directly on him when he lands
and i didn't notice this before he takes
out the drone by firing a web grenade
past it shooting the cliff side so that
another web strings forward
to catch a drone and yank it back in
prague beck gives peter a rooftop heart
to heart
just like tony stark did for him on a
rooftop at homecoming tempting peter to
share those stark legacy frames with
quentin beck while at the same time
frames are also used to lure peter back
to his teenage life
with mj offering to share opera
binoculars with him
even though they're definitely seated
close enough to the stage to need opera
glasses
mysterio's fire elemental attacks and
fury and he'll drive up in a car with a
license plate asm
28965 a nod to the comic amazing
spider-man released in september
1965 the debut of molten man which is
similar to this elemental monster but
mysterio's not expecting them to roll up
so
soon so when they pass in front of
beck's laser
bullet holes appear in the windshield
since the drones are using bullets and
pulse blasts to create damage
mysterio fakes a dramatic sacrifice
right in front of peter
making a power-up and a snap gesture
recreating tony's i am iron man moment
but before i continue thanks to bang
energy for sponsoring this video
it scares me every time to crack it open
but oh yes tastes so good
every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and has zero calories
and yet it tastes great with over 20
different flavors to choose from
one of those great flavors is blue razz
the razz
stands for razzmatazz which is what
raspberries taste like
also blue on those days when i'm feeling
real slow
sluggish a can of bang energy helps pick
me up so that i start to feel like i
have spidey scents which is just what
feeling energetic feels like
i think check out bang on instagram you
can get 25 off your order at bang
energy.com and use the code
newrockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea and keto
coffee flavors
you can also get clothing fitness
supplements all kinds of stuff to be
your best bang
self thanks again to bang energy for
sponsoring this video get 25
off at bang energy.com using the code
new rockstars25
and as peter parker mispronounces when
he does zero trips
proust prost probably and that leads to
this bar which is all set up to dc
peter in fact in the opening
establishing shot you can see
william guinta gintariva peering out at
us from under the taps like if you
happen to be looking at that corner of
the screen and remembered peter
billingsley was in iron man one with a
box of scraps
he'd be like wait and the music that's
playing is town called malice by the jam
lyrics describing the feeling of missed
opportunity being stuck in a bad place
instead of living the life you want
reminding peter how he is being forced
to grow up and be an avenger instead of
living his desired life as a teenager
team mysterio also strategically placed
military medals and a photo of glasses
right
over beck's shoulder to subliminally
trick peter
into seeing beck as a noble soldier who
deserves the edith glasses and then
another team member pickpockets peter to
make him think he carelessly dropped the
glasses
oh my god thank you so much what are
those are those the edith glasses yeah
they were just on the floor so we
learned that beck invented
barf which in civil war tony described
as an extremely
costly method of hijacking the
hippocampus
at hijacks the brain justifying how
these drones are so deceptive
actually in the next episode of the big
question tommy and i break down the full
functionality and implications
of mysterious tech you're gonna want to
check it out see mysterio's victory
plays out over a vigil mural of iron man
with tony stark's face inlaid inside it
a reminder that it's not the suit
some man inside the suit peter just
handed off that legacy to the worst
person
idiot i love how after peter reveals
himself to mj the camera pans around to
reveal
ned shocked in the corner just like the
gag in homecoming when ned found out
about peter himself
beck wears a mocap suit reminding us
that this whole group is really just a
filmmaking crew beck is the lead actor
and director
boxcraft's william is the
cinematographer and visual effects
artist
gootz it's a screenwriter victoria
stages these electrical impulses in
specific areas to trick satellites so
she's kind of the location manager
and janus is the wardrobe designer and
little miss pickpocket is
your amc a-list app fury picks up peter
in a car
tagged mtu 83779 a nod to
marvel team up issue 83 released in july
1979 which teams up nick fury and peter
parker but again it's another lie in
fact all this is a mysterio illusion
it's kind of insane to break down all
the little creativity that went into
this
fakery let's do this one last time for
this series a fake down
mysterio includes the detail of fake
fury reacting to hill being an illusion
to trick peter into later trusting fake
fury thinking he's not part of the
illusion mysterio projects peter back in
his high school in his past suit
triggering peter's anxiety over
balancing high school with avenging he
punches the wall where he thinks
mysterio is cracking it which the vfx
artist based on the truman show
when truman be manipulated crashes into
a wall that he thought was
sky mysterio uses peter's eiffel tower
mj plan against him here
tricking him into diving into a
shallower drop than he thought it was
and then peter asked if on a bullet
train
zips over to queens a threat by mysterio
that their next target could be his home
peter touches the mirror gets stuck to
it which the vfx team based on the
matrix
and the spider-man clones dog pile on
him like smith on neo in matrix reloaded
there are these
massive crumbled statues these are
actually the four avengers who died or
retired during the infinity war in-game
movies cap has crumbled on the ground
beside peter peter's actually standing
on his shield
black widow and vision are still
standing stark's head is on the ground
while his body remains standing with his
gauntlet outstretched then peter's at
tony stark's grave
triggering peter's survivor's guilt and
then iron man zombie crawls toward him
yikes kind of like the legless ultron
sentry or something out of the evil dead
and then peter stuck inside the snow
globe of new york with avengers tower
the pile of snowys on is actually the
pile of gravel in the construction site
outside
and then behind fake fury the swat
officers
are frozen because they're parts of the
illusion still
and then the truth hits peter like a
train a literal train
which peter doesn't see coming because
earlier when he moved like a bullet
train that was an illusion this time
it's real he is all messed up
and that disorientation lasts through
him seeing happy happy is that you
is it me yeah of course it's me yeah
those vibrant flowers are
likely further throwing peter off what
are we in midsummer everything's
colorful this can't be real holland and
holland
what flash's instagram feed shows that
his account name is
spidey number one fan and if you look at
the comments most of them are bots
this poor guy has to buy his followers
now in the suit lab on the jet include
alternate designs
including the spider armor mark 1 the
superior spider-man suit
his homecoming suit the iron spider suit
from infinity warden game and what looks
like the secret war stealth suit and
then later he makes his new suit for
what looks like
the spider armor mark ii and the spider
armor mark iii
i think yet notice that he does not add
the waste
web fluid storage that his past suit had
which leads to him running out of
webbing in london
oh great no webs and peter reaches into
the hollow gauntlet
just like tony did with this kind of
tech in iron man reminding happy of his
old boss
so he plays back in black by led ziplob
the ac dc and just as happy to open the
slab he uses this pinky
and thumb making the spiderman
wedslinger gesture
there's another scroll clue here i
thought cree having sleeper cells was
top secret information nick
yeah crease sleeper cells sounds like a
concern of someone involved in a cree
scroll war
one final clue comes later after the
battle appearances can be deceiving
of course setting up the post-credits
scene reveal in a car tagged hnm 6
2011 hawkeye and mockingbird number six
released in 2011 which included a scroll
posing as fury my guess is that the real
fury
was working with the skrulls on the
sword space station called the peak
after increasing his taser web voltage
peter uses this function to take out the
drones from the inside out then after
his cool flip he gets hit with a sonic
cannon
confirmed to be the same tech from the
stark designed sonic cannon used on hulk
and equipped on war machine civil war on
the bridge there's a car
tagged m95 xlv xlv being roman numerals
for 45
for the astonishing spider-man number 45
released
in 1995 which was the debut of she-venom
and since mj's running past it it could
be a nod to
mj's future possibly an infected patient
from a symbiote
now there's a drone that chases them
into the tower of london notice its
thermal scanner tml there
is inactive explaining why it can't
detect their body heat
meanwhile peter uses the bridge sign as
a shield and the explosive drone piece
flinging it up at him similar to cap and
in-game holding his shield out while
swinging mjolnir
by the strap up at thanos peter
rediscovers his tingle he blindfolds
himself to trust his instincts and
break through mysterio's misperception
why aren't these drones firing
you're in the strike zone the chance of
getting the fire
all the drones now now he's clearly
behind the drones
like peter caused them to get hit
otherwise he wasn't in their strike zone
in that moment
really beck wasn't this far down the
hallway he was actually much
closer to peter within the line of fire
either strike zone warning was a clue
that this back at the end of the hallway
is another projection and notice how
beck
points his glasses at peter like a gun
his finger
around a trigger there his final words
are haunting
people need to believe and nowadays
they'll believe anything and peter never
does get literal confirmation that he's
dead
is he is this real
[Music]
all illusions are down peter the
misperception lives on peter kisses mj
beside an upside down mercedes tagged
tsam143
that's for the amazing spider-man issue
143 which featured peter's first kiss
with mj
the car being inverted could be a night
of that upside down kiss
of toby and mj and then pull my neck in
the final scene peter glides through a
new atrium constructed into
avengers tower which many of us believe
could be in the process of being
remodeled into the baxter building in
the fantastic four
actually as peter approaches on the
lower terrace
there is definitely an orangish blur
with a bit of blue in there
which you know in my head canon could be
and definitely is
ben grimm or you know a squirrel
pretending to be him
on the street level there's a barrier
wall that reads we are so excited to
show you what comes next with a timeline
showing the numbers one two three and
what comes next i think it's four for
likely referring to phase four
or the fantastic four hopefully both g
jonah jameson shows up played by
jk simmons as he was in the rainy movies
this spider-verse is getting real
interesting
the daily bugle is now an infowars style
conspiracy show
airing mysterio's doctored footage
framing and outing peter
spider-man's name is peter parker
calling back aunt may's final line in
homecoming what the [ __ ]
yeah it's one of the darker endings of
the infinity saga like sure peter
overcame mysterio to regain his tingle
and inherit tony's vision but
misperception as a whole
wins the day it's a reminder that after
all this we still live in a world of
false narratives
in which privacy is a thing of the past
and so concludes our infinity soggery
watch
thank you so much for joining me for
this ride it's been amazing
eye opening content providing actually
stay tuned for my official ranking of
all 23 mcu films
also some deeper theories for upcoming
marvel films based on the new clues we
found during this process
there's been a lot of stuff and of
course more rewatches coming your way
starting with sam raimi's spider-man you
can join these watch-alongs on discord
by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars
follow me on instagram ea boss follow
new rockstars and be sure to subscribe
because you are not ready for what comes
[Music]
next
[Music]
foreign
[Music]